i'm really heartened by the relatively
unified response out of the west the
appeal by president zielenski saying hey
anyone who wants to come fight with us
will give you weapons and him like legit
hunkering down and bearing arms and
fighting it's been one of the most
inspirational things that i can remember
zolensky is by background a tv actor who
played a president in a sitcom so it'd
be the equivalent of i'm going to say
tom hanks becoming president but there
is so much performance involved in being
a political figure at this point where
if you can get in front of a tv camera
and give a compelling speech off of a
teleprompter that actually is a very
important skill the qualifier yeah
you're qualified for the job yeah
and so would a world-class actor be
excellent at that 100 yes zolensky was a
comedian president and is now the real
president and that's now the real
president but there were a couple of
ways it could go and the way it went is
that zielinski
has hunkered down and said this is my
country i don't need a ride i need
ammunition let's greet them with molotov
cocktails like the whole thing has been
extraordinary i think he has
legitimately shamed the west into
helping
because he's willing to sacrifice so
much his country men and women are
sacrificing so much you're like okay we
have to get with the program and help
this country help this man and i think
he single-handedly turned the world
sentiment in a particular direction yes
[Music]
you